حدث ما كانت تخشاه منظومه الامن
الاسرائيليه عمليات فرديه فلسطينيه ردا
على تصعيد الاسرائيلي الاخير والذي كانت
احدث حلقاته التوغل في جنين طفل فلسطيني
من العمر نفذ عمليه اطلاق نار في حي سلوان
في القدس ما ادى الى اصابه مستوطنين بحاله
خطره واحدهما ضابط في الجيش الاسرائيلي
نحن نتجه نحو الصعيد اوسع العمليات اللي
في حدثت تثبت انه منعها امر شبه مستحيل
ولا يوجد حل لعمليه فرديه والشعر الوحيد
الذي يمكن ان يوقفها هو ان يسود شعور
الارتياح في الشارع الفلسطيني
لعناصر الشرطه في جميع المناطق بعد عمليه
مستوطنه النبي يعقوب الا ان التصعي بقي
سيد الموقف
اليهود يسيرون باتجاه حائط مكه وعندما
التقي بهم اطلق النار عليهم معدى الى
اصابه اثنين لاصابه خاطره
الامني المصغر للاجتماعي بتشكيله الجديده
تشكيله تخلو من الخبره وان لم تخلو من
الوزراء ذوي الاراء القوميه وهم ممكن ان
يدفعوا باتجاه اجراءات تصبوا الزيت على
النار وتفاقم الاوضاع بدلا من تهدئتها
خاصه بعدما توعد بين كبير المتطرف برد
قاسم على الفلسطينيين تعتمر اسرائيل لان
هذا النوع من العمليات الانتقاميه الفرديه
هو الاخطر والاصعب وستكون بمثابه امتحان
للحكومه اليمنيه الجديده التي لا تملك
الكثير من الخيرات للتعامل معها في ظل
تصعيد ميدانيا مستمر قد يكون شعله
الانفجار الميداني كبير لان كل غاصي من
القدس العربيه